James what would you say to that person
that just can't get that first project
off the ground well no one's asking for
your film let's start there no one cares
about you no one wants to hear your film
no one wants to hear story because they
don't know you exist I don't mean that
in a harsh way but they don't care about
your film and so if you want your first
film to be made unless you're
independently wealthy which I was not
independently wealthy being the child of
teachers I had to figure out how to do
it I had to figure out how to put money
together my first film was a short film
called the car wash with a dear friend
of mine named Edith IV who is still with
us he's almost 91 now and she agreed to
be in my film because she liked my
script and I figured out how to finance
it by making high-school-graduation DVDs
with a camcorder having a basic package
for twenty dollars where you would get
gesture college graduation on a DVD but
for 30 dollars you could get an upgraded
package with a exclusive
behind-the-scenes photo gallery before
graduation and your name printed on a
disc 80% of people bought the deluxe
edition even though there's not really a
big difference between the two but then
I was able to use that money to channel
it into making my first film I was able
to fly Edith to States or Savannah to
Statesboro I was able to pay for a hotel
do catering all of these things I was
still in college and I didn't have money
but I made enough money to pay her sag
student fee I may enough night to do all
those other things and it was because I
looked at things entrepreneurially and I
said how can I do this one thing to do
this other thing because nobody cared
about my film and a big heard about me
it's like oh you're not you know I've
never made anything who cares you're in
college whatever I made it happen for
myself and because I made that choice
and because I
cast the right actor because I took it
to film festivals because I went to
those film festivals all on my own dime
not because I'm independently wealthy
again I was able to get to a point where
now people give me checks to make films
and it was because I took that
initiative so it's not big it's not that
you can't make your film it's your
choosing not to make it because you're
choosing not to take that leap there is
no guarantee when you take that leap
that you will have that wonderful series
of events happen none I was just lucky
that people liked the film that I made
and so the best thing you can do is
write the best damn script you can make
get the best feedback you can from
people you know from people that happen
to work in the industry if there's an
online script service that can review
your script whatever it is take the
notes take the feedback don't reject it
embrace those things because you
probably don't know what you're doing
yet because you haven't done it and then
make it the best film you can make and
then take it to festivals put it on the
internet do every you have to do and
then do it again and it's gonna still
take you a while before people give you
a check to make a film unless you
suddenly get you know 20 million hits on
your on your film on YouTube or if it
wins the Jury Prize at Sundance right
it's very unlikely that you're suddenly
going to start getting checks and so you
have to keep doing what I did which is
do something else
use that money to make something and
over time I start shifting from having
to spend my own money to spending other
people's but with that comes entirely
different sub challenges entirely but
you keep saying lucky can I just
interject all you also sound very
organized and very disciplined well you
have to be and and that's the best
Moscow that you're born with I don't
think that's a skill that you learn but
I mean I do sincerely believe that there
is an element of luck I know you're
probably tired of me hearing that word
but there is an element of luck but of
course there also is and that is the FIR
thing preparation discipline and
hopefully some talent too because you've
got to figure out how to get to that
point where you want to be and if you
are not prepared organized ready when
the day comes you're making two features
at the same time they're not going to be
ready to do it because you don't know
how to get there you don't know how to
structure and discipline and deliver
because it's very different when you go
from a point where well this is $1,000 I
raised of my maid to make it a little
short - I'm now spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars or millions of
dollars of someone else's money that has
to be made back because it's a business
it's not personal anymore that's that
transition and so if you can't make that
transition of discipline no one else
will ever give you another multi-million
dollar check to make a film ever again
in your life won't happen
you